and radula zone your sword wherever you  first prepared to lead of the temple in  my heart and where was that heart tested  in the field of battle by the grace of  God rise master of the temple and find  outs of the Grail I should not be master  and I am not worthy to find the krail  and who's not the Templar they think  he's there is an army on French soil  loyal not to you but to the Pope I can't  landry I cannot allow it  something has happened something  extraordinary can change everything  our regret is in France what better  symbol the leaders back to the holy Pope  must be dealt with and we must recover  the ground for ourselves the tumble is  not safe for you or the Grail this will  be the death of you  the armies of God will be reborn what  does this mean my lord it means war  I have given my life to the crowd  what kind of Queen would I be if I did  not defend my people  the ones we love the most are the ones  most likely to betray us  you  you